MONTHS, THEY WILL HAVE FRACTURED
TRUMP SPACE, I.E., HUGH.
>> Jason: WHAT ARE THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS POLITICAL
SHOWDOWN?
JOINING US NOW AS RNC CHAIRWOMAN
RONNA McDANIEL AND FOX NEWS
POLITICAL ANALYST GIANNO
CALDWELL.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING US
HERE.
RONNA, I WANT TO START WITH YOU
BECAUSE THE MESSAGING FROM THE
DEMOCRATS HAS BEEN ABOUT
ABOLISHING I.C.E., ABOUT OPEN
BORDERS, ABOUT SUPPORTING
SANCTUARY CITIES, NOT BUILDING
THE WALL.
HOW IN THE WORLD TODAY HAVE A
BURNING MESSAGE WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> THEY DON'T, JASON.
AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LEARNED
THAT ASYLUM CLAIMS ARE UP 1700%
OVER THE PAST EIGHT YEARS, WHEN
THEY LEARNED THAT 12,000 KIDS
HAVE COME HERE UNACCOMPANIED AND
THEY ARE BEING HELD IN    IN THE
THEY ARE BEING HELD IN    IN THC
THEY ARE BEING HELD IN    IN THR
THEY ARE BEING HELD IN    IN THE
OF HHS BECAUSE THEY ARE COMING
WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS TO TRY TO
GET INTO THIS COUNTRY, WHEN THEY
HEAR ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING, THAT THERE ARE
800,000 CASES RIGHT NOW PENDING
IN OUR COURTS FOR THESE ASYLUM
CLAIMS, THEY GO, THIS IS A
CRISIS.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
THE PRESIDENT IS COMING TO THE
TABLE WITH SOLUTIONS, VERY
REASONABLE, COMMON SENSE
SOLUTIONS, AND THE DEMOCRATS
REFUSED TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
THIS IS OWNED BY THE DEMOCRATS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY
MORE THEY LEARN ABOUT THIS, ARE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT DOING RIGHT BY
OUR COUNTRY, OR BY THE PEOPLE
TRYING TO COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO FIX OUR IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM.
>> Jason: NOW GIANNO, I HAVE
NEVER SEEN A POLITICAL PARTY
SUCCEED BY BEING ANTI-FEDERAL
WORKER, BY ATTACKING THE 20,000
PLUS BORDER PATROL AGENTS, BY
SAYING THEY WANT TO ABOLISH
I.C.E., THEY DO ALL THESE
THINGS, WHAT IS THEIR METHOD?
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS PLAYING OUT?
>> WITH INTEREST INCOME I WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS ON MY
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT.
I CAN TELL YOU, THE REASON WHY
THEY DO THIS IS BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THAT, HEY, THE BORDER
SECURITY FOLKS MAY NOT BE VOTING
FOR THEM, THEY SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IN 2006, BARACK OBAMA
HIMSELF SAID, U.S. SENATOR, SAID
THAT WE NEEDED SECURE FINANCING.
HE VOTED FOR THE SECURE FENCING
ACT.
PEOPLE LIKE HILLARY CLINTON,
JOE BIDEN, CHUCK SCHUMER, THEY
ALSO PART OF IT.
NOW THEY ARE AGAINST IT, BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PROPOSING IT.
IN ADDITION TO THIS, SEBASTIAN
GORKA MENTIONED SOMETHING IN THE
LAST SEGMENT THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CRIMINALS
THAT ARE CERTAINLY TRYING TO GET
IN, NOT ALL, BUT CERTAINLY THERE
ARE SOME.
IF WE LOOK BACK IN 2017, I.C.E.
COME OUT OF THEIR MOST FOLKS
THEY BROUGHT IN, 74% OF THOSE
FOLKS HAD PAST CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS.
THIS SERIOUSNESS POSSESSING OR
SELLING DRUGS, THESE ARE THE
HARD-CORE DRUGS, THE, SO
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
FACSIMILES IRREFUTABLE FACTS,
HOW COULD THEY NOT WANT TO
PROTECT OUR COUNTRY?
ONLY BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THEY
CAN CORRELATE SOME OF THESE
VOTES TO PROTECT THEIR PARTY AND
STAY IN POWER.
>> Jason: RONNA, PART OF THE
MESSAGING ACTUALLY SHOULD BE,
LET'S DO WHAT THE BORDER PATROL
WANTS TO DO.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THESE POLITICAL
PENDANTS, WE HAVE THESE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS WHO HAVE NEVER
TURNED ONTO THE BORDER, I WAS IN
CONGRESS FOR EIGHT YEARS, I WENT
TO THE BORDER MULTIPLE TIMES,
CHASING GUYS WHO HAD DRUGS, ALL
THESE THINGS.
MOST OF THESE MEMBERS HAVE NEVER
BEEN THERE.
WHY HAVEN'T THE REPUBLICANS THAT
SHIFTED THE FOCUS TO THE BORDER
PATROL, THE PEOPLE WHO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE EVERY DAY, AND
FOCUS ON WHAT THEY WANT?
THEY DO WANT THE WALL.
>> THEY ARE ALSO THE EXPERTS.
THEY ARE DEALING WILL BUY THIS
EVERY DAY, ON THE FRONT LINES.
IF YOU GO TO THE DOCTOR AND THEY
SAY, YOU NEED TO TAKE THIS
MEDICINE, WE SEE THIS ALL THE
TIME, WE DO THAT.
THERE IS I.C.E. AGENTS, THE CBP,
THEY ARE COMING IN COMPARISON,
WE NEED HELP.
WE HAVE A CRISIS, WE HAVE DRUGS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER, WE
HAVE AN INFLUX OF THESE CARAVANS
COMING, WE CANNOT MAINTAIN AT
THE CURRENT STATE, AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE NEVER LISTENED TO
I.C.E. AND CPP.
THEY VOTED AGAINST SANCTUARY
CITIES, THEY VOTED AGAINST
KATE'S LAW.
WOULD HAVE THE DEMOCRATS EVER
SUPPORTED OUR MEN AND WOMEN
SERVING AT THE BORDER?
IT IS JUST SHAMEFUL AND
CHUCK SCHUMER OWNS THIS 100%,
NANCY PELOSI OWNS THIS 100%.
REPUBLICANS AND THE PRESIDENT
ARE FIXING THE PROBLEM.
DEMOCRATS COME TO THE TABLE, DO
YOUR JOB, WE NEED TO FIX OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
>> Jason: NOW GIANNO, THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE SAID ALL
ALONG, HEY, WE ARE FOR BORDER
SECURITY BUT HAVE YOU SEE THEM
DEFINE WHAT THEY ARE THEY'RE
SUPPOSE IT'S A PART OF BORDER
SECURITY ACTUALLY IS?
WHAT ACTUALLY IS THAT?
>> NO.
THEY PROBABLY DON'T KNOW.
THEY WON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN
FINDING AN ANSWER.
HERE'S WHY: THEY REALIZE THAT BY
2045, THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
A MINORITY RIGHT FOLDER.
SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THERE
WERE NO LONGER BE 50% RIGHT.
THAT IS WHY THEY HAVE ABANDONED
THE WHITE WORKING CLASS, THAT IS
WHY THEY ABANDONED THE BLACK
COMMUNITY A LONG TIME AGO
BECAUSE THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT ANY ONE THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THESE NEWER AGE, NEW
GENERATION HISPANIC INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO BE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS COMES DOWN
TO.
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE TO AT
LEAST ASSESS THE POWER AND
CONTINUE TO CLIMB UP THE LADDER.
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN
PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT THEIR POWER
BASE AMOUNT IS WHAT I BELIEVE
THIS COMES DOWN TO.
>> Jason: REAL QUICKLY FOR
EACH OF YOU, HOW DOES THIS
PARTIAL SHUTDOWN OF THE
GOVERNMENT, HOW DOES IT ACTUALLY
COME TO AN END?
RONNA?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO HOLD FIRM.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO CAME TO
WASHINGTON THEN AND SAID ENOUGH
OF BUSINESS AS USUAL.
HE TOOK ON ISIS, TRADE DEALS,
HE'S LOWERED TAXES, HE SAID THE
IMMIGRATION PROBLEM IS A CRISIS,
WE ARE GOING TO SOLVE IT, AND HE
IS NOT GOING TO BLINK AND
DEMOCRATS NEED TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND FIX THIS PROBLEM.
IT IS THEIR JOB IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THE MORE THEY LEARN
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN    AT
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN    AE
BORDER, ARE GOING TO SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT IN THIS ISSUE.
>> Jason: GIANNO, QUICKLY, THE
PRESIDENT HAS FINDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT, NOT ONLY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., BUT ALSO THE
MEDIA AS WELL.
HOW DO YOU SEE THEY SHUT DOWN?
>> IT CERTAINLY IS GOING TO TAKE
DEMOCRATS COMING TO THE TABLE.
DO THEY HAVE ANY INCENTIVE TO
COME TO THE TABLE?
LIKE RUSH LIMBAUGH SAID, NOT
UNTIL JANUARY 3RD, THEY HAVE NO
INCENTIVE.
THEY WANT TO MAKE A POWER PLAY
HERE.
BUT IT'S THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
THE COALITION GROUPS CONTINUE TO
PUT THE PRESSURE ON THE
DEMOCRATS, WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE CASE, I LIKE WHAT
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY SAID.
A PRESIDENT TRUMP GET IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA SENT US AN ADDRESS
TO THE CONTRARY, STATING VERY
IMPORTANT, WE COULD SEE SOME
MOVEMENT AND CERTAINLY SOME